you buy a bench on Christopher
double-double type identities for the
independence bono Thanks
first of all I would like to thank the
organizers for this or a nice worship
and yeah I would like to speak about the
independence polynomial and some
community role and algebraic aspects of
it which could or might be helped us to
understand the roots or at least we are
trying to understand what's the between
the structure of the graph for example
and between the roost and so first of
all I will use igx for the independence
polynomial for today so I will denote by
I G X we have the family of independent
sets F in the graph G so just to be sure
that we are speaking about the same
partition function if this is the graph
this is my polynomial okay so there is
zero there is exactly one empty set
which is independent we have five one
sides of independent set and there is
exactly three non edges of this graph
okay so so we are so some motivations
for the independence polynomial is that
basically we like it because it's for
example it is the partition function of
the hard core model right also we really
like it because it's somehow help us to
to understand how far we can extend the
luvstruck' lemma by keeping the same
dependency graph also it it could encode
various comunitaria objects from the
from from the fields so for example
largest independent set largest matching
in the graph
all the matchings of the graph or all
the clique coverings of the graph so
all of these can be somehow encoded as a
independence polynomial and so we could
so the next thing what I would like to
speak about this Christopher darboux
identities these identities are well
known in in the theory of orthogonal
polynomials so and I so what is this so
whenever we have an orthogonal sequence
of polynomials there we can always find
positive real numbers such that this
quite long but useful identity holds and
this is called the Christopher darboux
identity so I don't so I don't need that
what what is exactly the orthogonal
polynomials I just want to give you the
the flavor of it that how can be useful
this long expression okay so for example
this kind of expression could be really
useful in order to find roots proving
that the orthogonal polynomials has only
real roots for example okay so let's try
to prove it okay so if we are believing
that this this identity holds okay what
would be our strategy to to prove it
let's take the smallest counter example
okay we take it and then choose a
complex root of it right which witnesses
the non-relative ness okay and then what
to do let's use this formula and plug X
I and site conjugate at x and y okay
what will happen on the left hand side
we will have this will be 0 this will be
0 and therefore the upper part will be 0
since we choose
complex roots so x- slide will be a
nonzero number here so this left hand
side is a big 0 and what's happening on
the right hand side the right hand side
what we will see is the conjugate of the
same quantity so these will be Lance's
of complex numbers these are positive
coefficients so the right hand side is a
positive number so we get the
contradiction yeah and I we didn't check
the the base case of the induction but
this is the moral feeling how to prove
such a thing so and and later on God
still Chris Coatesville generalized and
introduced identities for matching
polynomials and he called them as
Christopher darboux identities because
somehow there are the this identity can
be found among the among the matching
polynomials also so I think this is how
he picked this name so he introduced a
bunch of new identities for matching
polynomials and what I was able to do is
to generalize or found some similar
identities for the independence
polynomial so what is it so we can take
this expression which could be quite
familiar from the first saw so this is
something like correlation right so we
are deleting the vertex U and then
deleting we the - without deleting and
then deleting you won't be right so the
left-hand side is this correlation say
and and what is true is that the thing
will be as I said long formula so this
is a summation over all
he used bipartite sub graph of G which
contains U and V okay and I denote by
this bracket D close neighbourhood of
the sub graph okay so it's quite similar
in some sense that on the right hand
side we have something to the square or
this is right now it's not a two
variable identity it's a one variable
identity but it's quite similar so from
here we can for example prove that if we
are so lucky that the the distance of U
and V in any bipartite induced sub graph
is the same priority okay which is the
case in a bipartite graph so in a
bipartite graph and in your sub graphs
you and we will have the same distance
up to parity then we could get this
correlation so we get positive
correlation and negative correlation for
all positive x what we use here I have
Assumption bipartite here so in so when
we are using this theorem for a
bipartite graph G that this D HUV will
be always the same on the right hand
side here well your set is the
is a set of bipartite connected and used
cigarettes so I'm just wondering about
that the third line oh yeah yeah why
the reason why is that the reason yeah
so yeah so the reason is that that if
you consider so let's imagine we have
two independence so we have one
Independence Parliament we take the
square of it then what will happen that
that we can imagine that each when we
are taking the product we will take a
monomial from one side and from the
other side we can think as as the
independent sets also so in some sense
the the product of two independent
independent polynomial will be a
partition function of such a colourings
where two colorings are independent sets
in other words if we project it down its
bipartite graphs and then used so this
is how they come into the picture yeah
so this is what I basically try to start
it to prove here so what's he just used
it for for closed closed free graphs I
think so okay so here's identity is only
for droppage whoops yeah yeah so in
cloves it will became much nicer because
this this set will be much nicer
so so the proof how's it look like so we
can define configurations as as
bipartite graphs in the original graph
and we will for each configuration we
will give them different weights
depending where they are coming from
okay
so if somebody's came from here it will
get some weight and so basically imagine
that we take two independent sent from
this graph and this graph and then the
disjoint Union and this is H and then we
can just calculate what is the number of
easily isolated vertices of H other than
u and V what are the connected
components of H of size at least two
which is not u not we okay and then we
can define four sets which put so the
first three will partition see depending
on U and V is in the in the bipartite
graph or not or exactly one of them is
in the graph and the third one is a
subclass of the third of the forces
occurs a subclass of the third where we
we put the condition that u and V should
be in the same bipartite component okay
and now what we can do is that we can
express using these classes of this
product so it's quite technical but but
this is the summation what we will gain
for G minus u G minus V and if we do the
same calculation for g and g u minus V
we get the same terms here except the
last one and what is this last one that
H is a bipartite graph where u and V is
in the same connected component and
their distance is even
this is this is here and in the previous
it was odd the distance so this is why
we will have in the formula minus 1/2
the distance of U and V plus 1 ok that
will decide the sign and all of these
will disappear ok so that was the the
idea behind the proof yeah I have to
mention this is a simplified proof
YouTube so there is another formula what
we can write up now I write it
immediately the second line so this is
the expression so here we have all the
bipartite connected induced sub graph of
G this is the summation and and we will
have here P and R they are the
cardinality of the size of the color
classes okay P is one of one side R is
the other side okay
and it's really symmetric in in changing
xn myself okay so and now I'm stating
that if you just believe in this formula
okay
we can give a short proof for the Co
free to the students beside more theorem
which says that cloth free graphs has
rebooted independence polynomial and why
is that
so first try to I saying we will use
this formula so what we have to
understand is this set so all in used
connected bipartite sub graphs of a claw
free graph
since claw freeness is as a induced
the chlorine s of so induced sub graph
of a cofee graphical free that means
that we are looking for bipartite
connected clue free graphs that are
nothing else but even cycles and passes
okay but in an even cycle or in a path
the difference between the two color
classes is at most one okay so this full
whole thing can be written in this form
okay where r is the smaller cardinality
of the color class okay and I just
divided by Y minus X to be make it more
nicer and now we can use almost the same
argument as before so assume that we
have a root complex I and put sign
instead in X and put side con you get in
Y then the left hand side will be 0 so
it's not disappearing it's appearing
here it's because now we have two
variable now it will separate them so
there we had only x-axis and not so if
you write X equal Y then you get 0 so if
they are just related so you can derive
from one to the other
basically yeah so this is the shortcut
of janeski same with here so but what we
the intent of janowski's similar elusive
completely different or it's okay it is
completely different but it's the same
proof as poodle asses that's what as
Bordeaux las yes this the same proof but
that is your identity the same when it
comes when Porto free graphs so when he
does this he used he creates some bounds
on depending on the I I cannot recall it
exactly right now that but he uses some
he creates some bounds of it so if we
know that the mean imaginary part is at
least a we know what is the imaginary
part then it will give us a lower bound
on I think in this expression or
something like that for 14 for the claw
free graph is the same essentially is
the same yeah but he somehow I don't
know he'd go in a different way
and and you know so this statement holds
in multivariate sense also and Jonathan
you you generalize this for multivariate
independence polynomials and and you
sure that they are same face stable but
yeah yeah but this holds in in
multivariate case that I think yeah so
and I think this is what's happening
there also yeah so we can wonder what's
going what we really used in the
children's Cosima theorem and it turns
out that basically what we really used
is this difference between P R a pH and
our age what was that maximum okay
so the maximum difference between the
two color class okay and it turns out
that if we just really use this bound
this Kappa I didn't know any name for
that so what we can state is that
whenever we have a root it cannot be lie
in the P divided by Kappa sector okay
basically the same proof as as the
previous okay there Kappa was exactly
one or at most one so pi divided by one
so we get back exactly the same
statement what we just hired so this is
a sector freeness result what we can
obtain from this formula and and we can
wonder what kind of graphs can be can
have bonded Kappa okay so so the first
class is clearly the at most one it
turns out yep
because it's about induced graphs so
whenever I so be was the set of all he
used bipartite connected sub graphs so
if I take a smaller graph this set will
be just smaller so the maximum it could
be only smaller
okay so if I say at most Kappa then it
is a directed graph so what are these
classes so we can ask for one this is
what we saw this is the closer graphs
you may wonder what is two and it turns
out these are the graphs that doesn't
contain even lengths double Fork okay so
this is an infinite list of graphs I
don't know why the name of them I don't
know any subclass of it but these are
the forbidden sub graphs K can be at
least zero okay so the K won't for is
there so this is the forbidden sub
graphs now ya induce pass of lines to
cake
this is an induced graph so yeah the
dots missing there and also we can ask
for three here the the family is two
parametrized so this is one guy and this
is the exceptional one so these sets and
I don't know how far it can be counting
but yeah this is like a question for
maybe for the audience that do you know
any nice classes which is contained here
or we can say any boundedness so but on
the other hand it it rises the question
that really the clothes causes the
causes this distribution of the roots so
if I have more clothes I will be more
bigger I will be not that many really so
I will be further from the real line
okay and and the question it is somehow
is settled so basically we have to look
at look the past three the self avoiding
past three of the graphs do to scored
soccer bites and this will solve the
problem because we know this this
identity and we really like it but the
question here is that can we give more
insight of this ITX okay so the
independence point of the self avoiding
work tree and it turns out that yeah it
has some nice properties first of all
its maximum degrees at most the maximum
degree of the original graph fine but
it's also true that we can identify a
subtree of the self avoidance or tree
such that whenever we take the
independence polynomial of the
complement of this subtree we can use
polymer polynomial division and began we
can get back the original in the pendous
polynomial so the whole independence
polynomial divides the in depend
of the sap avoiding watery independently
how we create this elf avoiding watery
and also what's true is that in this
case the tea is a product of induced
subgraphs independence polynomials so
it's more more true
so not just divides it but all the
factors are induced subgraphs and so how
can we use this so so for example the
starting graph is a clover graph okay
and we create any self avoiding work
tree of it then the result will have a
tree okay
and we know that that the three
independence polynomial will be the
product of induced subgraphs of the
original graph but a clover graph has
closed free sub graphs only that for the
independence point of the tree will be
reroute adore so so now it's chose and
you know whenever we start from a clover
graph we create this tree it will have a
bunch of clothes okay so really like we
can have a lot of clothes but still
rebooted graphs okay and this is
basically in substance it is used in on
on Monday stock right yeah so the
we are taking buses where we connect to
vertices if their distance is Atmos K
what you gain is trees basically that
are being routed okay another
application of that whenever we have two
graphs and they have the same set of
voiding walk tree and one of them was
clothed free then automatically the
other will be rerouted okay so it could
happen there are examples that can be
proven this way oh and also the another
really important property of this
independence polynomial and the SAP
avoiding walk tree which is the
following that whenever we take the all
but all the routes of the independence
panel up to a degree D okay this is a
large set of fruits and we can ask how
is it related to the roots of all the
trees okay with with bounded degree
condition D clearly one contains the
other but it turns out because of this
divisibility relation these two sets is
exactly the same so why is it good for
us because there are techniques to find
v-0 free regions for the hardware model
and usually what when they are doing
this kind of recursion thing there is
always a last step a last step is to
handle the trees when the the root has
exactly D child okay so usually usually
order all the proofs works nicely till
the point that everyone has exactly D
minus one done down children okay but
sometimes we have to solve the cases
when the root has exactly D
d child but you know in a tree we can
always choose a vertex which doesn't
have exactly D neighbors it has a leaf
at least or two so we can hang the tree
from the leaf okay so in other words if
we are aiming for a root free so saying
that lambda is not a root for any graph
of degree at most D it is equivalent to
the fact that we can find a set which
contains zero doesn't contain minus one
and it's invariant under this map okay
where we are specifying only D minus 1
variables okay and this is enough to
check we don't have to wriggle one more
step and I think so this is how far it
goes so this is the Monday's result
about zero freeness of of the hardcore
model I do to Monday so so we have the
Shira region here the biggest disc and
here the F lamb that what they used was
disc then then it was shown by Rex and
Peter's that zeros are accumulating to
this blue curve and they also showed
zero free region this this brown one and
they showed zero freeness around the
real axis the other boundary then with
chuck party we were able to show that
there is no roots in a bigger region
this pink which is contains the first
region of deaths and
here we used trapping region a sip
circular sectors and recently on yeah
and then pewter proved that yeah these
this kind of there are thanks
so there are curves which which cutting
in into you D and sorry these are not
precise image so I just throw some
curves there so anyway to these curves
also we know that there are accumulating
there are zeros that accumulates okay so
there are infinitely many roots inside
this big cardioid and wandering at SRI
Toshiba on on one day they they said
that yeah they they computationally they
can show that there is a nice region
here where which is 0-3 and what they
used trapping region there is some kind
of sequence of curves yeah yeah so this
is what they approved and and I think
quite recently you can say more
somewhere here usually something here
yeah some extension actual extension of
this
we have to get a better handle on yeah
so thank for your questions questions um
could you tell us so remind us if these
verdicts and dependents polynomial to
satisfy it didn't satisfy his delusional
you know the deletion contraction final
finishing ownership for math for well
sorry but the recurrence okay sorry now
patient confection okay yeah so IG acts
in one variable this is I G - you delete
the vertex okay so you are counting all
the independent sets which not wanting
you then you have to count all those who
can't cup contains you whenever you
contains you you have an ass a
multiplier and then you have to take the
close neighborhood of you out of G so it
does satisfy delicious attraction it's
it's a recursion so yeah it's almost
it's almost contraction is it it makes
me
it's almost dilution contraction so my
question is there is no contraction so
in summation the dilution of Jewish the
edge yeah the actually defensible Naaman
satisfies the lesion contraction but
this one is satisfies it like this weird
thing anyway my question is just because
you have some form of deletion
contraction oh say you have this whole
class of polynomials that would meet
just this requirement could you derive
your Kristof of they're both from there
you can derive crystal der heul 4000
polynomials from their recurrence
relation yeah
so hence my question ya know could be
very interesting to try yeah never talk
about it and may make just a remark on
your sectors that you're obtaining this
might be completely irrelevant but two
of my co-authors and I have a paper
where the sector's arise from matrices
various you know specific structure
which we call generally scored it's
matrices and if they are totally in a
magnitude then this region says 0-3
regions will will be guaranteed so
that's a subject of the paper so again I
I don't know if hand if there ain't an
actual matrices that will be leading to
total negativity but maybe there are
sort of lurking in the background yeah
other questions or concerns
smoke let us thank the speaker again and
the we